[Music]
root wants to know your personal
stories or connections to the arecibo uh
radio telescope uh
uh because of course it collapsed
recently and uh and
and charlene uh would like to know will
it have an effect
on how we scour the heavens uh for
possible alien communication or
life yeah so the arecibo telescope was
the
largest telescope in the world for
decades
right ever since it was built until back
in the 50s or 60s
uh no no when was it built i think 1960s
until
uh just a few years ago was the largest
telescope
in the world and in telescopes in
astronomy in general
bigger equals better because if you're
trying to collect rain
outside that's coming down imagine the
rain or just photons photons
okay and you want to collect it you can
use a thimble you can use a bucket
you can use a cauldron or a swimming
pool or a swimming pool you use the
swimming pool you get the most amount of
uh raindrops so it's that simple it's
not more complicated than that
so bigger equals better so
as a since it's a radio telescope it
listens it it
observes radio waves and pulsars gives
off radio rapidly rotating
neutron stars gives off radio waves it
can also detect
things happening in our ionosphere right
this is a part in the upper atmosphere
that's electrically charged
right and old-timers will know
that you could get am radio
from very distant cities late at night
and the reason why you could do that is
am radio waves
once they were broadcast by the antenna
would reflect
off the bottom of the ionosphere and be
able to
cover more than the curvature of the
earth that you could see
from your where your your radio was
whereas
fm goes straight out into space so
if you want fm across multiple cities
you need repeaters and
all sorts of other that you need all
manner of of ways to get that signal
into other places
now of course it's everything's cable
driven and satellite driven i'm just
talking about in the day
right so it could observe phenomenon
going on in the ionosphere
in fact the funding originally for
arecibo
was enabled by the u.s military
to detect the signature of decoy
intercontinental ballistic missiles as
they re-entered the atmosphere
through the on the ionosphere as
launched by russia
what this is how okay so don't get me
that's
sensitive listen this is don't get me
started
on well you can but not in this moment
on the two-way street
between astrophysics my field and my
people
and the military oh man we gotta do an
explainer on that
we are all my people we're all generally
sort of liberal
anti-war this sort of thing but at the
end of the day
the stuff that we care about the
military cares about stuff the military
cares about we care about so we have
strongly overlapping
venn diagrams in what we do and what we
invent
and what we innovate so anyhow so the
money for that telescope
was driven by the us military and we
knew all along
we could piggyback that fact and make
all manner of other discoveries
so it also gets us it does
radio echo echoing so what the telescope
could also do
better than any other telescope was send
a signal
back out to space okay because you think
of telescopes as just receiving
right but what you can do is take a
signal
send it from where the location of the
receiver
bounce it back off the telescope and
send it somewhere in space that you
designate
okay so there are asteroids
which are too small to really
carefully track using optical regular
telescopes
so what you can do is to take a radio
signal send it out
beam it back out to space to an
asteroid and that then the reflected
signal comes back to you you time it
you get the distance to that asteroid
and when you get the distance and you
know which way it's going you get its
orbit
and you need you you want to know
what those orbits are for asteroids that
cross earth's orbit
because they will eventually 100
hit earth so it's like an echo locator
you not not with sound of course but
still
but but with with radio waves uh
bouncing off and coming back
and so this is uh so it's a highly
useful telescope
in that regard now all right several
years ago
okay um china says we're going to have
the biggest telescope in the world
and so they went up and built a bigger
telescope twice the collecting area
of the our sibo telescope twice
twice twice around twice i forgot the
exact math but it's about twice
and that's the deal with china
what i'm trying
so so they too found a natural crater in
the earth as
we found for the rsibo telescope and
built
the largest radio dish in the world
and has an acronym it's called fast the
500 meter aperture
um spherical telescope so its shape is a
spherical
it's right it's it's the geometry of it
good for them
oh so i visited that we we shot some
scenes there for cosmos
for a whole episode of the other grass
tyson communist chinese
[Music]
wow that's so cool so you want you got
to see it okay yes i was there
so it's a mile in circumference wow all
right if you walked around the upright
anyhow here's my point the question was
do i have any relation
yes i do my mother
my mother uh while she's born in new
york city her parents are from puerto
rico
and in fact her grandparents are from
aracebo
puerto rico oh cool so we have genetic
connection back to the town
that's the nearest town to that
telescope wow on the island of puerto
rico
and so that's first connection second we
would go visit relatives you know every
christmas
and you know christmas in puerto rico
that's a whole thing
yeah that's a whole by the way at
midnight you're there usually through
new year's
at midnight there's a tradition you eat
grapes one per 12 grapes one perc
a tone of the clock right okay and one
year they got grapes but the grapes had
seeds in them
so i was like you know
and i was like eight or something it's
like what do i do with the seeds don't
eat another great quick
you gotta do one third
so my point is um
the oh so the telescope will be missed
in that regard but it was
falling out of disrepair we've known
this for about a decade the
the national science funding foundation
started with drawing money
for support for it so that means your
maintenance doesn't work out
no one writes the article about the drop
in those funds
they wait until the damn detector falls
out of the sky
and then they talk about it as a tragedy
it was a tragedy
that had tap roots that goes back a
decade
wow so for me this plight
of the rebel telescope is metaphor for
science in america
excellent first you the funding drops it
goes out of this repair
and then a few things break putting the
rest of the structure
at stress points because an engineering
design
system if you start taking out support
struts then the rest of it
can't it's designed to be complete if
you start yanking out pieces of it
because it broke
and you don't repair it then that's the
beginning of the end
yeah which in fact it was the beginning
of the end and now the
the the detector falls down out of the
sky
and it's the end of an era and so now if
aliens gonna talk to humans
by sending radio signals um they're
going to be speaking
chinese the chinese will be the first
to have that conversation with aliens
now so i'm as an american
i i'm i'm upset that we can't lead that
effort but as a scientist i know
that if you if your country becomes
short-sighted in terms of their
investments
the science can and will still get done
it happened with the super conducting
super collider that we were going to
build
in texas funding began then it all got
cut to zero
but europe said we'll build one so
europe build at the
the european center for nuclear research
cern
um they have this the the large hadron
collider and they just
they discovered the higgs boson the god
particle they discovered new frontiers
in particle physics at cern and we
didn't
okay science doesn't care what your
nationality is
all that matters is who who who is
offering you
enlightened leadership and enlightened
governance
if you want to be on that frontier
otherwise you will
dance to the tune played by others who
have made those investments
in the future of this civilization wow
man that was good well sorry that's a
long answer to that no it's a long
answer but i got to tell you the um
the message at the end of that answer
you can't
it's all worth it yeah what's the price
of admission i'm just saying
[Music]
okay
[Music]
you